in the light of the crisis facing your
company and in the interests of rearing
the trust of the flying public
have you considered resigning I think
the important thing here again is we're
very focused on safety and I can tell
you that both of these accidents weigh
heavily on us as a company I've had the
privilege of working for the Boeing
Company for 34 years and we know that
lives depend on what we do we take that
very very seriously
and I've had the privilege of doing that
for my entire career and I can tell you
that our Boeing employees as well take
that very seriously and so I'm very
focused on safety going forward it's
important that as a company we have
those clear priorities that we're taking
the right actions that we have the right
culture I am strongly vested in that and
my clear intent is to continue to lead
on the front of safety and quality and
integrity that's who we are as a company
and I think it's really important to
continue to stress that and we we deeply
regret what happened with these
accidents it gets to the core of our
company I've had the chance to walk the
factory floors in Renton where we build
the Macs airplanes over the last few
weeks and a chance to talk with our test
pilots I've had the opportunity to talk
with our engineers to the core of our
people they care about this business and
the safety of our airplanes that's what
I'm focused on